and we also like to take a look at some
acting not every movie features the best
in acting sometimes the act can be
pretty bad but we have found that bad
acting sometimes goes all the way around
to become exquisite acting this week's
exquisite acting comes from Paul Vincent
Ginter in Cherry Hill New Jersey Cherry
Hill here we go right across the bridge
for my hometown do you wanna build a
snowman
ride our bikes around the hole let it go
Paul sent this and he said with Stephen
King at the top of the box-office world
again
let's not forget the time he tried his
hand at directing one of his own stories
[Music]
electronics came to life yeah the
premise of the film was a comic goes by
the planet Earth and the tail of the
comet causes all of the machines to
attack humans like it does you know what
comet does that big stand out thing
about that movie that we all love Mike
came out even though the movie was
disappointing was at the front of the
truck it had a big green goblin face
that's right that was the bad guy but he
was doing [ __ ] comics and there it
was like the Green Goblin
so you would go see that movie and there
were no comic-book movies and [ __ ] like
that but you could be like oh my god the
[ __ ] a great Goblin that's the
closest we'll ever get to a spider-man
movie Paul says let's never forget the
truly exquisite acting of Ellen Mikkel
d'If if you don't know her name she is
the actress who plays Wanda June the
waitress at the Dixie boy trucks down
she is most famous for yelling we made
out all the machines as they try to kill
everyone over and over again so that is
this week's exquisite acting we've got
two clips for you first her establishing
her character and then second her
satisfying death
[Music]
[Applause]
that's [ __ ] exquisite she used her
whole body to deliver why did she but it
makes it all that much more sweet when
she finally gets well exterminated by
the machines
[Music]
[Music]
that old movies filled with exquisite
anything but none more so than Ellen
Miguel de forever she is tonight we
salute you
I forgot the [ __ ] music whenever
somebody dies
[Applause]
[Music]
you